Target stock is down 15 combined Target
and Bud Light have lost around 28
billion dollars in market share and this
really does matter because it seems like
the tides are turning in the culture War
there's an article from New York mag
where these leftists are shocked to find
that conservatives and the right were
actually able to pull off a boycott and
actually set a market shift
but now we're seeing more companies
Chick-fil-A hiring a diversity equity
and inclusion VP so this stuff is
spreading plus we got a baseball player
from the I think the the Blue Jays
bending the knee and engaging a struggle
session because he supported the target
boycott we have to talk about this stuff
we've got a lot of uh news and I think
the big story here is that last week CBS
I believe it was reported that there
were bomb threats at various Target
locations without verifying they posted
a screenshot of an email that was
purportedly sent to us at timcast.com we
never received that email that's fake
news so I don't know where they got the
email I don't know if it was a spoof or
a hoax or what however we did receive
similar emails but not the one they
posted so I think it's it's obviously
some kind of spoof I am mildly perturbed
they did not reach I just say hey did
you receive this your emails on this so
I'm assuming someone must have sent them
a screenshot of a fake email that they
then posted saying like oh look it's
real or something without checking and
then a bunch of other outlets post the
same thing TMZ posted the same thing so
we're gonna break this down and go over
what's really going on but there were
several Target locations evacuated this
stuff's getting pretty spicy and I think
when you look at this baseball player
apologizing and saying he will be
re-educated you need to understand just
How Deeply entrenched we are go read
1984 or any one of these books we're at
the point of re-education we've been
here for some time so we need to address
it especially when Chick-fil-A is doing
the stuff there is a lot of other news
too we're originally going to lead with
Tara Reid Joe Biden's accuser she
claimed that he assaulted her sexually
assaulted her she's fled to Russia now
the guardian reports she's defected
that's an interesting story and then of
course World War III is in the news
today because this morning Moscow
suffered multiple drone attacks on
civilian targets so we'll definitely get
into all that but I do think that we
should focus on uh you know I was trying
to figure out what I thought was the the
bigger story but I think American
cultural breakdown with the elections
coming up you've got Trump you got to
sandus we should be focusing on our
cultural issues uh in this episode but
we will absolutely get into all the war
stuff before we get started my friends
if you want to support companies don't
hate you go to castbrew common buy this
gas Brew Coffee Appalachian nights we
got rise with Roberto Jr with every
purchase of rise with Roberto Jr you get
a picture of Roberto Jr right down the
back of the bag and we're going to start
rolling out new pictures collectible
bags they fold up you can do whatever
you want with them but uh this is ours
this is our coffee company so if you
want to support us go to casbrew.com we
are opening coffee shops hopefully we
can have many of them all across the
country maybe we just do a very simple
franchise model where we create the
general idea of what we want to do with
the space and then we just let people
open their own and then boom overnight
we'll have a thousand locations across
this country and when you walk in to go
buy your coffee there's a TV it's
playing Tim cast another TV it's playing
crowd another TV viva viva and Barnes so
that we can push our culture into these
spaces but also don't forget to go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight and if you're a member for at
least six months or you sign up at the
25 per month level you can actually
submit questions potentially call into
the show so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Seth Weathers
great to be here I am on casper.com oh
wait start over I said great to be here
I'm on casper.com because I feel bad I
have not subscribed but I'm gonna get
the subscription for the coffee yeah it
smells amazing it's really it is good
it's actually very good and I'm actually
just about to uh crack open this uh
Ultra right conservative uh dad's beer
100 woke free American Beer we'll see if
we'll see if he's wood free after this
is over
oh wow that's good I'm impressed I'm not
a big beer guy that's pretty good
so who are you what do you do aside from
you know I'm drinking your beer uh Seth
weathers uh launched this beer company
about a month and a half ago at this
point and at this point in my life I do
nothing but
um manage a beer company so it's taken
off we we put out a video an ad that I
think probably a lot of you your viewers
have seen because you've played it out
there yeah you put it out the day we
launched it and um on my Twitter account
alone I think we have over 46 million
views which is nuts because I don't have
some huge Twitter account
um and it's just continued to get
traction you know I think overall online
between all the different places that's
been placed we're probably about 100
million views like you don't start a
beer company and have that kind of brand
ID it's it's wild yeah it's actually
really I'm not a big beer guy I like
Yingling I like this yeah yeah it's a
solid beer you know it's not you know
this came out of the Bud Light
controversy but I do want to let people
know this is not a Bud Light knockoff
because I I don't think Bud likes is a
real beer
by the way they were actually Suited and
lost millions of dollars for literally
watering down their beer in the past oh
wow so a lot of times what they're
telling you alcohol content and
everything else they've literally been
busted for that how do you water down
water yeah well well it's actually a
horse I thought I thought wait isn't Bud
Light isn't Bud Light seltzer
well so so this is your main thing right
now right yes this is this is the we're
growing a lot we're currently brewing in
Georgia and we're also brewing in
Florida now and we'll probably have
people in other places around the
country uh contract to brew this uh beer
and it's again the growth has been wild
it's people like your listeners and you
guys uh uh literally you that have
helped support this and uh get it off
the ground and it's in you know it's
it's something that
there's a lot of people that said this
would never happen you know they said
they'll they'll never find someone to
brew it especially not with that very
dirty word conservative right on the
bottle which was bold and dangerous but
we did it they said we'll never get it
brewed we'll never get it bottled you'll
never get a distributorship you'll never
get license you'll never get Federal
approval these are all things that we've
done in 45 days for one of the highest
regulated Industries there is in America
and it's it's wild that's even happened
in that a lot of the right doors open I
was telling Ian earlier it seems like
every time a door shut a better door
open I know that sounds cliche but
that's just kind of how this process has
been and you know it's it's it's
exciting to see I was excited to see
conservatives stick through a boycott
but let's let's get into all that stuff
we've got a lot to talk about because I
think this is sticking is expanding
we're seeing the corporate press start
to freak out over it so Seth thanks for
joining us we got Seamus Coughlin
drinking a beer over here yeah I mean
it's cold I like it it's good it's like
a light beer with a little bitter kick
to it it's it really is really is good
they didn't pay me to say that I I've
enjoyed my my first couple uh sips of
this I'm Seamus Cagle and I have YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we just
uploaded a video today that I think you
guys are going to enjoy
it's about American public schools and
the way that the left usually portrays
them and satirizes them as being Rara
pro-america uh and then what public
schools are actually like I think you
guys are really going to enjoy it we had
a lot of fun we took an extra couple
days on it just to throw more visual
gags into it we were going to upload it
last Thursday but we spent extra time
with it so it's a really solid piece and
I think you'll all enjoy it
uh Hey everybody uh welcome back it is
Tuesday welcome I hope you had a good
Memorial Day man I'm in Crossland Seth
so would you consider this a light beer
because I'm drinking now it is light it
has kind of a light effervescence to it
legally I cannot print on that can that
it is a light beer without some kind of
federal testing or something we have to
go through
um but I would say you know for me I
would call it a you know a mid-range
between white and I guess full-bodied
somewhere in there so again it's not
like a you know like a Bud Light which
again I think we were kind of making
jokes about is just a pure flavored
water so we're not that so it's a real
full flavored beer you know I think
you're kind of feeling a gap because
Budweiser maybe it was an American
company at some point it's been sold to
AP and now it's our Belgian company
correct their headquarters in Louvin
Belgium so thanks for making an American
Beer Company 100 made in America right
on well that's Ian for you
he's back we got surge here and uh yeah
I'm here guys I hope you had a good
Memorial weekend as well and uh thanks
for the beer Seth great job yeah can I
just mention something here about this
beer and a lot of the other products
that are being launched by conservatives
now this isn't the case for all of them
there are some that are still
Outsourcing but uh I know even some of
those are trying to bring more
manufacturing to the US in the long run
and that's kind of the point I want to
make which is one of the advantages of
all of these conservatives bran uh
conservative Brands blowing up in
response to left-wing Shenanigans is
they're starting more american-based
companies
absolutely well let's jump into this
first story and we'll talk all about it
we got this tweet from Mark J Perry says
get woke go broke Target shares have
dropped by 15.3 percent in the last 11
days since the boycott started over
lgbtq friendly kids clothing
representing an eye-popping loss in its
market value of 11.4 billion the story
from Fox Business they say Target and
Bud Light investors lose billions on
marketing misses Target Anheuser-Busch
have lost a combined 28 billion dollars
in market value the target thing stands
out the most to me because this wasn't
look I understand the Dylan Mulvaney
thing Dill mulvanians don't move any
audience are our children domovany is
effectively just playing a character
like Borat or you know or um who is the
other character you played Bruno was at
it yeah that's one of them
that's basically what Dylan Mulvaney is
doing and when people see that they're
put off by it they're angered by it
they're assaulted by it they say hey we
want an apology it's also an adult male
playing the role of a little girl yep
which makes it even more yeah that's
like Bruno that's like it's it's it's
it's right it's it disturbs people what
I've heard from many people is uh and
I'm not trying to be overtly derisive
but people said disgust yes and so what
you know at first I was saying of the
Bud Light boycott that people just don't
want to be associated with an effeminate
beer then I had people saying like no
they actually they look at it with
disgust because it's Associated now I
can understand the boycott there's very
strong the emotions are very strong the
thing with Target is that this is just a
company doing their typical pride month
thing all of the companies are gonna
start putting the pride month stuff out
there Target now losing billions
11.4 billion in market value for doing
what companies have done for some time
that marks a massive shift that's why I
think the story is so important because
typically these companies do this stuff
nobody bats an eye conservatives don't
do a thing but now we're experiencing a
Cascade in the uh an exponential gain in
what in the Bud Light effect that is yes
someone's here's how I described it
earlier
somebody's holding shares stock in
Target and Bud Light
let's say they got 100 of each
hypothetical number
and they're told don't worry the Bud
Light thing will blow over boycotts
never work and they say okay and they're
sitting on 63 per share now it's at 59
and they're going dude I just lost like
eight percent because you told me to
wait so they sell that triggers the
price going down even more but they're
also holding Target stock let's just say
type at a hypothetical number X and then
the controversy breaks they go nah I am
not going to wait around and lose
another 10 they sell now there is a fear
in the market being brewed
doesn't matter if you actually oppose
wokeness it doesn't matter if you
support wokeness all that matters is if
a company gets woke their stock will go
down and that will create a
self-fulfilling prophecy and I think
what happened with the whole Bud Light
effect as you call it which is a great
term is it gave conservatives confidence
because we had zero reason to be
confident in any type of boycott I've
said for years we've got to pick one
company I've said this for probably 10
years we've got to pick one company
that's done something it's got to be
something we can live without we can
certainly live without horse urine I
don't want to get you a mark on YouTube
here
um we got to pick one company that we
can do without and go all in and cause
permanent economic damage until he calls
permanent economic harm to one of these
companies it'll keep happening we skip a
couple football games but we're back in
the stands three weeks later three games
later they don't give a crap they know
that all the conservatives will be back
they cave every time we'll have a blip
for three weeks if this sent the message
that oh wow these guys are sticking to
it they're angry and when people see the
effect of the Bud Light thing it's like
you said it's self-fulfilling now
they're wanting to recreate it they're
they're energized and they have a
confidence level of hey we can't
actually do this as conservatives like
wow we do have half the buying power
take a look at this story from New York
mag
just asking questions is the is the
section Bud Light Target and a new era
of corporate caution by Benjamin Hart I
love this he says initially he thought
nothing would happen he says uh I
assumed it would have little to no
effect instead it has delivered a major
hit to Bud Light sales he then goes on
to say why do you uh he says uh do you
think okay let me start over how unusual
is it for a campaign to be working this
well and do you think those factors are
why it's been so successful ladies and
gentlemen Pat yourselves in the back I
mean this is significant this is going
on two months now and it's only getting
worse for any of the brands associated
with the with with the cult yeah and
this is extremely encouraging to see you
mentioned a moment ago the fact that the
Bud Light boycotts went very well
significant damage was caused to a
company which was pushing something
horrible I remember when the target
boycotts began one thing I said was we
need to be very careful about ensuring
that we stick to the Target boycott
because this is going to determine
whether the Bud Light boycott was a
fluke
or whether conservatives have them as a
market are going to retain this power
well yeah they've got to be if the thing
is if we jump out there too quick and we
start trying to boycott everything yeah
real quick where none of them will be
successful agree and we will start
losing our Effectiveness which is back
to what I was saying we have to cause
permanent economic harm to a large
company and Bud Light is so far been
that company and it looks like their
brand man
I've never seen a brand destroyed so
quickly and so succinctly ever they're
not going to be able to just come back
and all of a sudden you know they've put
out bottles with camouflage bottles they
just put out a Harley Davidson special
edition bottle oh my God like it's just
harming Harley-Davidson is not bringing
their brand back and so again if we
stick to it I don't know how long a
Target
boycott will last uh that it's it's it's
harder for a lot of people to do without
it's not about the boycott though that's
that's the important thing no I get what
you're saying on the other side of it
but just saying as to what what
conservatives will actually stick
through and holding the feet to their
fire economically I don't think
conservatives actually boycott a Target
I think regular people got pissed yeah
so I see two things happening Bud Light
was a boycott it was high profile
individuals then what this guy points on
the New York Mega article is that people
boycott so the media picks it up so the
news spread so more people boycott with
Target I think
something was happening before the news
even broke
we started seeing these videos pop up of
people complaining then then news broke
of Target saying they had confrontations
well hold on that was not enough time to
have elapsed in when people on Twitter
saw videos and when confrontations could
have happened yeah I think regular
people walked into Target and went yo
WTF I got my kids with me I don't want
them seeing this stuff then they filmed
videos then Target responded what we're
seeing now with Target stock collapsing
is connected to Bud Light but it doesn't
matter what so here's the important
thing look
when uh the way I explained this last
week was that I knew this woke woman and
she Inherited property from her family
in New York and she was talking about
marginalized people and all of that
stuff and I asked her if a black family
moved next to her her property in New
York would she sell and she went of
course
and I was like are you kidding I was
like that's racist I was like why would
you do that and she said because
property value goes down and I was like
are you kidding me it goes down because
people like you do this and she's like
yup and there's nothing I can do about
it so I'm not gonna be the one who gets
economically hurt by the system
what people need to understand is that
the biases I've talked about this before
this is this is systemic bias the market
responds to fear of the market yes and
we've now created that because of Bud
Light it does not matter what people do
going to Target all that matters is the
stock will go down yeah that means you
could do absolutely nothing and people
holding Target will lose money because
of the negative press causing them to
panic sell causing the price to go down
creating a Cascade effect I'm reminded
of this quote that's attributed to Mayor
and shell Roth's child who founded the
Rothschild banking Dynasty which was
like the precursor to the the world the
banking this liberal economic order
banking Dynasty is the Ross Childs they
said that he said give me control of a
nation's money and I care not who makes
its laws so when you talk about having
control of money it's not necessarily
who prints it that's not where the
control ends it's how you spend it and
when you get enough people to come
together to choose how to spend their
money and and how not to spend their
money you are more powerful than any
amount of lawmaking and this is it's
shown with this this A B inbev drop in
11 of their stock value and targets
dropping 11 I mean you can you can make
Bank runs that's the most powerful force
on Earth if you want to talk about like
and I'm not advocating for that I
thought a lot about that over the last
15 years like wow I could just tell
everyone to pull their money out on a
certain day at a certain time but it's
like that almost feels like economic
terrorism you know but that amount of
power that you could to move the market
and control Earth I think yeah Congress
commits economic terrorism on us every
single day yeah it's their job I I you
know this phrase economic terrorism I
was just going to mention this because
you're absolutely correct that the
people have a tremendous power I mean
this is called the dollar democracy you
can choose where you spend your money
and companies are afraid of that that is
why they're trying to label what's
happening to Target a kind of economic
terrorism they're referring to us as
extremists for not wanting to shop there
anymore it's because they're scared I
think as long as you're not trying to
hurt people and destroy the system
there's no Terror involved you have no
responsibility or yeah uh to spend your
money anywhere the inverse the terror is
when antifa's like you must support
these things or else or when they burn
Target down like they did like they did
Target got burnt down by BLM in a riot
and then they issued a statement saying
we support BLM yeah that was amazing
boycotting Target because they're
pushing the gross groomy lgbtq agenda on
to kids and Target was like well this is
completely unacceptable you have no
right to do that did you see a lot no
target said we're so sorry we're gonna
hide all this stuff in the back and then
whisper to the LGBT community saying
don't worry we got your back so well
they did kind of like what Bud Light did
we're hiding it in the back because
these conservatives are so dangerous
they're going to come hurt you and then
one thing that I like to point out that
a lot of people missed with the whole
Bud Light thing you know everyone
there's all this talk you hear
constantly that oh Bud Light they fired
their VP of marketing they didn't fire
anyone yeah I know exactly hey leave and
if you even read their statement as to
why she went on paid leave at the end of
the statement it you know I don't have
it in front of me right now I could pull
it up I guess it says something to the
fact of being concerned for the safety
of our employee almost implying she was
in so much Danger from conservatives by
being out in front they never disavowed
anything they
I want to jump to the story from
Newsweek ladies and gentlemen the latest
update in the sales numbers coming
through this morning at 7am Bud Light
sales dropped
29.5 in latest week oh 30 percent we
round up we round up here 30 that is
massive anecdotally that is brutal dude
we were at a hotel over the weekend and
they had drink tickets from 537 free
drinks I was like great I'll get a I'll
get a beer I'll get something IPA
they're like the only free beer is Bud
Light did you notice
so for Real Estate yeah it was Spotlight
and one other bud
and so they know it's gonna go bad
eventually and so it's gonna be worth
literally zero to them so I mean that
economic situation yeah to remove it how
long does beer last it depends on the
beer and the bot even down to the cans
um it's again it depends on the beer in
the cans like I mean it's some people
say different times you can easily have
a beer for six months but you gotta keep
in mind some people say way longer I
wouldn't say but you got to keep in mind
those beers are on the Shelf you know
they came and got in put it put on the
Shelf on Thursday right that beer was
not canned with a company like Bud Light
That was not canned you know the week
prior this is a massive process with
these things so they've been traveling
around the country depending on where
they're at does it get better like over
time like wine uh no definitely not yeah
it's more bitter more like Ranch it
flattens right if it flattens I don't
know that I would say rancid I meant try
to super old beer so I can't really but
I do know it goes bad check this out
they say according to data by bump
Williams Consulting and Nielsen IQ
provided to Newsweek in the week ending
May 20th sales volume the number of
units of beer sold declined 29.5
compared to the same period last year
while sales revenue was down 25.7 on the
same look
this is this is not just a success that
that we were reading a previous article
for those just tuning in talking about
New York Magazine why it's so successful
success is an understatement success is
like
someone boycotts a product and then the
sales drop in the single digits and the
company apologizes a week later and then
you move on this is 30
two months later this is this this is
brand ending apocalyptic the fear
is is probably Rippling through all
these other companies Target loses 11
billion dollars in market value and they
explicitly said we fear a Bud Light
situation yeah you know we've talked
about this before you just touched on it
a little bit earlier
a huge part of this is the fact that
we've politicized issues that should not
be political right forcing this stuff
onto kids shouldn't be a political issue
and your average person knows that
they're perturbed by it without being a
member of a specific political party
even if the Republican party is the only
one which will stand against it your
average person isn't a fan of it and
when it comes to Dylan Mulvaney your
average person is grossed out by Dylan
Mulvaney they don't want to I mean look
a man in a dress is a very off-putting
thing especially a man in a dress who
really thinks he's a woman Chick-fil-A
is doing it yeah well Chick-fil-A is
going to get themselves into some
trouble there but all I'll say is this
this isn't just ideologically charged
this is your average person as you
mentioned building up an association of
disgust with a brand I just want to I
don't think personally I don't think a
guy in a dress is gross it's it's a guy
that pretends to be a little girl that's
when I start to be like what I think
that makes it way worse I think that
makes it way worse they both are gross
to me but I think that makes it way
worse it would be another thing if
in a play and the guy just got they just
cast an adult man as the little girl in
the play I can even suspend my disbelief
for the sake of entertainment but it's
when it's like people are saying I'm
really this way I would want to question
the person that made that casting yeah
anything is not just that it's it's a
man you know dressing up an address it's
not that it's a man pretending to be a
little girl it's that Della Mulvaney is
intentionally insulting everyone well
and budweight was asking you to Elijah
so let's remember the whole purpose of
the can was celebrating 365 days of
being a woman but the canvasion no I
understand but I'm saying the whole
point of them doing a sponsorship with
her was in their words celebrating him
being a woman for 365 days except what
what initially started this wasn't just
the can it was a video of Del mulvani
grabbing a stack of Bud Lights putting
them down and then the media claimed
ever everyone's mad over a single can
that was sent as a thank you having
nothing to do they're they're lying
Dylan Mulvaney's Instagram post has a
like you know Bud Light contest hashtag
don't move any places a bunch of Bud
Light says thanks cracks it open talks
about their program and how you can
participate or whatever it was clearly a
direct Bud Light sponsorship having
nothing to do with the can the media
tries twisting it and lying because they
don't want regular people to know what's
going on but here's what I see
you name it Dylan Mulvaney is the
negative marketing element you've got
people who are like wow why is this guy
just like a little girl you've got
conservatives who don't like men and
dresses as Sheamus described it Ian who
is not conservative but still be like
this acting like a little girl is
extremely off-putting I agree with both
with both to a certain degree but I
think Del Mulvaney insults women Dill
Mulvaney insults trans people and Del
mulvani insults liberals and like
literally just insulting everyone in any
way imaginable and I think it's on
purpose the there was a video that went
viral of Dylan watching some movie and
fake crying and once again They're
laughing in the background They're
laughing at Dylan fake crying and I
don't think they're laughing because of
the moment I think they're genuinely I I
think Douglas hey guys watch this watch
this
do you see that wasn't that funny and
then they're all laughing they're having
a good time mocking people and I think
Dylan's exploiting the algorithm and
that's why Tick Tock is propping up
these videos dude the video of Dylan on
Twitter where he's like I feel like now
I'm attracted to women I told my dad
he's like well good I hope you get a
girl pregnant he's like no no she's
gonna get me pregnant huh and it's like
dude he is joking he's a he's a a
goofball like the dude is pulling one
over on the human race it's Borat yeah
it is Bruno it is a person like so again
we we've mentioned this before
but this is what was was we've we've had
a couple I've had a couple trans social
media personalities tell me the facial
hair removal laser stuff is the easiest
and cheapest thing to do and Dylan has
not done it but well I think that Dylan
is a very good example of Poe's law
right you're all saying that you think
it's an act because he's clearly being
ridiculous but we're at a point where
reality is indistinguishable from satire
basically that the idea that at some
point it becomes incredibly difficult to
tell the difference between somebody's
sincere opinion and satire because of
how ridiculous things have gone yeah
that is true if you pretend to be
something you kind of become that thing
yeah well and and also it's this idea or
the way it's usually used is to express
that things are so out of control right
now that you can't tell if somebody's
serious when they they say something
because even just a few years ago it
would be a joke or if someone else said
it would be joke for example I won't say
state it out loud but we asked a certain
left-wing commentator if performing
certain acts a
activities on the male body uh is gay
and he said not if it's on a woman but
it's awesome and that's Poe's law
because that's like a joke but right
beyond that he said I I have no problem
it's Lance from the surf he's on the
show he said that if a man engages in
relations with a masculine ugly woman he
is gay yeah and and Ian was like that's
not cool man you can't call someone gay
because her girlfriend's ugly like
it's like for real like that's kind of
messed up like they're they're they're
they're pretty sure that's happened but
well so I think you're right I think
what happens is Poe's law is a good
example of what happens on the internet
Dylan Mulvaney goes in hiking heels
wearing high heels and dancing in the
forest and then falling down because of
a bug I think that's fake but kids don't
know it's fake and so they start
imitating these behaviors you then end
up with people like Lance who I think
he's 40 something years old genuinely
believing that is the left and then
going on a public show to millions of
people and saying if you date an ugly
woman you're gay and if you date a small
petite effeminate man you are not gay
it's like okay what dude I hear you but
I I think the difference is so part of
it is that it's indistinguishable I
think that is the left this means all
bears will be surprised to learn that
their twink boyfriends make them
straight
I mean I got well because he well he was
also saying we can't have hot or not
right so it was it was all very good for
yourself several yeah but I I guess my
overarching point is things have gone so
off the rail and the left's morality
surrounding human sexuality in in
quote-unquote gender which is a term I
hate is so insane that it might seem
like someone is joking it might seem too
ridiculous to believe but that doesn't
mean it's not real well do you think um
satire and parody are like are like
satanic no I don't think so because I
think they can be used to highlight
truth but I think that what happens is
the world can become so insane that
something which in any other era would
be a harmless joke is now something
taken seriously so here's a great
example there was a bit in Monty
Python's meaning of life where a child
is born and they give it to the mother
and the mother says is it a boy or a
girl and the doctor says well it's a bit
early to be assigning roles to it don't
you think and I remember seeing that 10
years going going oh my gosh they made
this joke decades ago and this is
actually about to be a massive social
justice issue quote unquote and it is
now so so I don't think that it was evil
for Monty Python to make that joke I
think the direction that our country has
gone in is evil you know you know what I
was thinking earlier today
gen Z and Millennials are literally
idiocracy now an idiocracy was a was a
lot of gag humor and stuff but I was
thinking we did this video segment uh
last week Isabelle Brown had a clip
where this comedian's mocking gen Z for
being unable to write in cursive unable
to use calculators or find directions
and newspaper maps and this will work or
or work but seriously they don't want to
work polish so they don't want to do
work I'm aware and she said that if gen
Z take does take over it'll be really
easy to take it back and then Isabelle
Brown makes the point like you were
supposed to teach us I was thinking
about that and I'm like it's not just
gen Z Millennials too are completely
incapable uh Sheamus and I were talking
about one of the guests we had in the
show
a lefty and he said something like if
you want to cover health care just
deficit spend print the money to pay the
bills and I said okay let's start from
the beginning where does food come from
and his response was at the grocery
store and I was like this was an adult
an adult human male and is what is he I
was he 30s or something and we're like
no food doesn't come from the grocery
store it gets it goes oh my like okay
first you have a farm they make the food
then it gets sent to like maybe like a
regional processing plant where that
particular food item is processed that
has to get bottled shipped to a bottling
plant then it gets shipped to a regional
Warehouse where it's then sent depending
on the product you have sometimes fruits
are directly handled right there on the
farm sent to a regional distribution and
then right to the supermarkets if it's
like uh so I knew somebody who did Honey
one company would go and collect all the
honey from 50 small farms bottle it at
their plant and then distribute it so
there's three steps but no not the
grocery store thinking about that I
realized we're in Idiocracy yeah we're
literally the point where you walk up to
the guy and say well where's the food
grocery store in Heavenly and you're
like no food comes from farms what it
comes from the grocery store and you're
like oh my God yeah but by the way I
don't uh I don't want to mention uh who
it was and the conversation was off air
but it wasn't Lance
was not Lance I want to know tell me off
air yeah yeah and and but but I've had
numerous conversations with people where
I've talked about this I had one
conversation during the lockdowns where
I tried explaining I was I was tweeting
to somebody and I said they were talking
about
food in the grocery store and giving
people money and they were like the
government should just start giving
people more money to cover their bills
while we're locked down and I said right
but money represents labor right so if
this if if you're creating the means to
acquire without creating the means
themselves like you're going to create
this inverse reaction he's like what are
you talking about that makes no sense
and I'm like let's start from the
beginning where does milk come from and
he said the groceries oh my gosh this is
what I tried on the market so so this is
one way I try to explain this to people
the economy is like a giant pizza and
the amount of currency you have is the
amount of slices in that pizza if the
pizza doesn't get any bigger all cutting
more slices into it does is diminishes
each slice now you could be in a
situation where I don't know you don't
feel that the pie given its size is
being distributed adequately so we have
to make more slices you can make that
argument but to say well the pie isn't
growing let's slice it up more is
idiotic yeah but then you get 2 slice
instead of one shot that's a good point
that's lit and that's actually the
reasoning when they say just print more
money you're just cutting more slices
into a pizza that's either staying the
same size or even shrinking and then I
and then I thought to myself I was like
we're in Idiocracy it's like we're here
have you seen how popular Crocs are
these days oh man yeah we're there all
right everybody I got bad news for you
oh it's time to bring up the the dark
news these are the dark days from
NewsChannel 8 on your side chick fill
A's Dei leader Sparks calls for boycott
that's right Chick-fil-A has hired a
diversity equity and inclusion officer
uh VP named Eric McDonald says
Chick-fil-A restaurants have a lot have
long been recognized as a place where
people know they will be treated well
modeling care for other starts in the
restaurant and we are committed to
ensuring mutual respect understanding
and dignity everywhere we do business
these tenants are good business practice
and crucial for filling our corporate
purpose blah blah blah they then go on
to list a whole bunch of garbage and
people and stuff like that at the bottom
they say that they have a commitment
to Dei look I'm from Georgia which is
where Chick-fil-A is is based out of and
literally was formed and founded
if there's any if there's a long-term
boycott of Chick-fil-A then
conservatives won everything because I
don't know that you're gonna pull that
one off because there's a lot of people
that are going to fight back on that I I
say I say boycott Chick-fil-A I'm not
saying whether you do not I'm saying if
it actually is successful I will be very
impressed because that's gonna be a very
I could not imagine a more difficult
company to talk conservative moms into
boycotting in my whole state of Georgia
even if even if you're showing them this
they will Overlook a lot and I think a
lot of those moms don't when you just
say Dei like look they're taking their
kids to 14 different practices and
running around all over the place and
you're trying to say Dei This and like I
don't know I'm just getting my kids
nuggets with a pleasant person that's
nice to me well I get what you're saying
with the argument for it I just don't
know that it it will be successful yeah
so it's easier to villainize Bud Light
sorry no Chick-fil-A I would agree but
this is also part of why this is so
disappointing to me Chick-fil-A has sort
of had a a bit of wokeness creeping into
it over the years in 2020 during the BLM
riots I believe that uh the founder was
supporting me like don't quote me that I
might have either been the founder of
the CEO but there have been a number of
issues there and it's a shame because I
was very proud to support Chick-fil-A
and what they were doing for quite a
while and I thought the left's reaction
to them was very fascinating and very
telling because the left said that
Chick-fil-A was evil and why was
Chick-fil-A evil well because one of the
uh owning members or CEOs or higher-ups
didn't spend the company's money but
spent his own money donating to an
organization that was not pro lgbtq that
was that was in favor of uh preserving
there's a church yeah and people lost
their minds over this now now think
about this for a moment Chick-fil-A is
known to not only be one of the most
profitable fast food chains per
franchise but
they're also known to be one of the best
franchises in terms of how they treat
their employees they pay them decently
especially as far as fast food
restaurants go and they ensure to give
all of them one single day off every
single week where they're not going to
try to profit off of them they're going
to give them a day to relax and be there
for their family even if it means
they're not selling their customers that
day the worst thing the left should have
been able to say about Chick-fil-A is
well it's morally complicated because
they should have appreciated the fact
that they treated their workers well but
they don't because they don't care about
workers they care about their sick
perverse sexual agenda and anyone who
opposes it even with just a whisper has
to be absolutely destroyed and I
remember the Burger King released an
advertisement uh during pride month
about two years ago where they said they
were releasing their own chicken
sandwich and their chicken sandwich was
in favor of lgbtq Rights and you could
get it on Sunday so in the same breath
they were mocking Chick-fil-A for being
anti-lgbtq and mocking them for giving
their workers one day off of work Burger
King should be ashamed for the way way
they treat their workers it's not just a
sexual agenda it is an all it is an
all-around cultural revolution yeah but
I think it starts with that I think
that's a huge part of it I I think it's
just absolutely obvious what this is
like we talked about this before but day
Dei literally is the Latin singular for
God these people are creating offices of
God but it's not it's a simulacrum
someone commented that a moment ago that
don't move into simulacra not the words
of my mind it is a false
image of religion that is being created
to substitute for people and they are
Marching In lockstep Like deranged
Psychopaths that's I think I think both
are true
the son Dan Cathy Jr is not his father
and if I had to make a prediction and
bet
all the beer in the world on it I would
say that Dan Cathy Jr is going to Cave
to the left Dan Kathy Jr who's that the
son or maybe the second junior or
whatever of the owner of Chick-fil-A
yeah uh true at Kathy's the founder and
then I guess oh I see Dan Cathy is the
chairman is he currently right but is he
a junior
I I disagree with you I think
Chick-fil-A will be one of the easier
things to boycott no I'm saying okay I
okay I'll bet you money on that one I'm
just a they're not a public company
they're not a public company which means
it's easier to pressure
no you can't kill you can't go after
their stock but but see the thing about
Chick-fil-A is that they already have
the disadvantage of being the Christian
company when it comes to the issue with
the left so the left is targeting them
very heavily and ignoring all these
other companies that have done anything
remotely similar I think one of the
funny things about the Chick-fil-A
boycotts on the left was that other
companies had made similar donations but
nobody cared it's because Chick-fil-A
was overtly Christian yeah yeah
Chick-fil-A my understanding what
they're trying to get into more urban
markets but because Chick-fil-A is so
pronounced conservatives have a have
identify with it and are now going to be
in my opinion much more offended by it
and you mentioned Suburban moms
dad might be like I go to Popeyes that's
all it takes all it takes is for the for
the husband of the dad to be like just
go to Popeyes honey it's it's across the
street the thing I get it but I'm from
Georgia and look I get the understanding
of like we should all this kind of stuff
but go to a Chick-fil-A in Suburbia
Georgia right now and you're not going
to see a lot of dads in there you're
going to see a lot of moms with a lot of
little kids and what I'm saying is when
Mom is like hey I'm gonna pick up the
kids after soccer and then we're gonna
go grab some Chick-fil-A and all it
takes is for him to say bring them to
Popeyes
if the mom doesn't care about the brand
at all
then the slightest nud should knock her
off no but the moms love the brain
that's not what I'm saying the mom's
absolutely love the Chick-fil-A brand
but like I cannot think of a brand the
Suburban moms love more than Chick-fil-A
at least
you don't have them up here yet dude not
really what do you mean we have them all
over the place we get Chick-fil-A all
the time yeah we order big things of
Chick-fil-A here we're not gonna do it
anymore I'm not gonna buy from them
to I would agree with you if every
Mall's got it I would agree with you if
the point was simply that you know
people are only going to Chick-fil-A
because of the more conservative values
the fact that they've been maligned by
the left but they have probably the most
efficient drive-through system of any
fast food chain they get you in and they
get you out no matter how long that was
absolutely wrong oh no that is not wrong
you cannot absolutely
correct Snopes fact checked what you
said was true Snopes agrees with you I'm
correct about Chick-fil-A's
drive-through is overloaded well explain
if there's one drive through restaurant
of one drive-through restaurant that
I've left it's Chick-fil-A and that's
your locations this was in Jersey and
down here okay in Jersey yes here's the
problem okay and down even here so
that's what I'm talking about in the
South maybe y'all don't have enough
homeschool kids here to run the
Chick-fil-A's like we do in the South
but that is like jokingly it is largely
run behind look man if you think the
moral fiber of The Homeschool kids and
conservative conservatives are so weak
they can't even push back on this then
so be it you're not going to have me
arguing the the strong moral fiber of
conservatives willing to stand up I've
been proud and impressed to see that
with Bud Light but we have a history of
conservatives of not standing up for
anything so that's uh you know again I I
get it but but also like about the
drive-through thing yeah crazy the lines
take so long and I understand it's an
issue of demand yeah but I I would say
every time I've gone to Taco Bell I
drive up I order I I when we live Mass
we we drive up we wait a little bit we
order we're gone Starbucks we wait a
little bit we drive up we order we're
gone Chick-fil-A we sit in line someone
comes out the window they take our order
we're sitting there a half an hour later
we get our food and I'm like there
there's there's two lanes to go through
there's an exit Lane it's it's insane
they they've prioritized their drive
through to such a ridiculous degree on
more than one occasion we've just been
like let's just leave and then we've
we've pulled out and left because it
took too long every time I've ever gone
there I've been extremely impressed with
how quickly I got through the drive
through like I've been to McDonald's or
Taco Bell or Wendy's with a line that
was a quarter of the length of
Chick-fil-A lines I've been in it took
five times as long that's my experience
it looks like it would be different in
the South I promise you this that could
also because but the thing is when
you're in the South like I'm sorry I
also lived in Georgia for a number of
years service is usually much slower
there but when I go to Chick-fil-A on
there it is like you are in and out then
go to the one here yeah I may do that
tomorrow no I'm boycotting Chick-fil-A
Tim come on no yeah I mean look
there they they've hired a Dei this is
more than just a promotional campaign
this is outright saying from the top
down they have put a a a cult
non-theistic religious office in their
in their business yeah and it is it's
worse than the Chinese Communist Party
the Chinese Communist party as a
government agency puts Communist Party
offices in businesses in China but it is
an element of government this is a cult
that is putting its tendrils in
everything and the and the story that
the media is running is that the right
is angry over like equality or something
like that they're lying of course
they're making up lies the reality is a
new excuse me non-theistic is a beer
non-theistic religion is now putting
itself in all of our businesses and then
forcing those businesses to destroy
themselves
unless like we're we're at the point now
where it may be the moral fiber of the
average American if you're right is so
pathetic that we're doomed
situation is that usually with this Dei
stuff when it's implemented my
understanding is it's because people
think that that will make their business
more attractive to venture capital or
shareholders but Chick-fil-A isn't even
a publicly traded company I I have no
idea
some kind of plans for Venture Capital
exactly
Etc but that's part of what we're you
know you're talking about the lack of
courage or
sticking through that's part of a large
part of one we created conservative ads
Ultra right beer and it was to encourage
people to make a stand and stick through
that stand and and you know Beer happens
to be the Catalyst and you know one
thing I was talking with Scott Pressler
about is we're going to use this as a
catalyst too we're gonna actually have
on the cans like a QR code where you can
scan it to register to vote because we
have tons of rural conservative
individuals that drink a lot of beer but
don't vote and so we're going to use
this as a catalyst to get those people
to do that that is brilliant tell them
to vote responsibly well I think if
they're drinking conservative ads Ultra
right beer there's a good chance they're
gonna vote okay
I want to pull up this uh the suite from
Samuel say this uh tweet helps you
understand why it is that companies like
Chick-fil-A get woke he says this is
serious Anthony bass is a professing
Christian he shared a post supporting
the target boycott now he's apologizing
for hurting The Pride community and he
says he'll better educate himself he is
betraying Jesus and his conscience pray
for him I want to play for you this
short clip of what he had to say here we
go I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine close
family members of mine and I am truly
sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates and
shared with them my actions yesterday I
apologize with them and as right now I'm
using the Blue Jays resources to better
educate myself to make better decisions
moving forward uh the ballpark is for
everybody we include all fans at the
Ballpark and we want to welcome
everybody that's all I have to say thank
you oh my goodness so this is him saying
he's going to get re-educated like no no
joke he says he's using the resource of
the Blue Jays to better educate himself
it's literally like we used to make fun
of this you know in The Simpsons they
get re-educated that's right the idea of
being forced to undergo a struggle
session under education we knew in this
country was a sign something was wrong
but look this pathetic Coward of a man
yes like this in hand pathetic and
that's back to what I was talking about
with the caving conservatives tend to
Cave yeah so this guy's how do you feel
Sheamus he's like he's a Christian
yeah I think he should have stayed
strong to his values as a Christian I
mean I don't know what to say I would I
would say he's not a Christian well I
can't I can't say he's not a Christian
but I can say that I don't think a
Christian should cave into a mob that's
trying to promote sin
to look up to him he's not a Christian
when I was a little kid I remember uh I
went to Catholic school and I remember
we were learning about religious wars
and stuff like that in a very limited
sense but I remember hearing about like
you know one religious faction would say
convert or else and then I always
thought to myself I was like why not
just lie just saying oh sure sure of
course I I hereby convert so they don't
kill you well that people would say with
them no they would say no exactly the
fact that this guy
in in what a day dropped to his knees
and bagged begged please I'll renounce
my entire faith if you just leave me
alone like dude his balls must have
shrunk down to the size of marbles and
sucked up right into his body three
times before the rooster crowd he denied
Christ from the way I heard that yeah I
mean I'll mention this when you say that
people would say convert or die and some
people would lie about that I mean in
part that's when you ask like why not
lie well they're okay with you lying
they're okay with you not actually yeah
to throw your beliefs under the bus so I
I definitely hear what you're saying
there they want you to profess to the
world that you give up yes and I think
it's very sad that he did this and I
really hope that he repents and turns
back to Christ
he was due to make three million in
2023. so that's what he's he's speaking
for the three million yeah if it's a man
nothing to give his soul and gain the
world in return you think that he would
have been better if he if he just stuck
to his word and got fired amen yeah
absolutely you know what's you know what
because they're persecuting him for the
sake of the king him he should embrace
it right what's what is it it's easier
to fit a camel through the island it's
easier for a camel to pass the I have a
needle then for a rich man enter the
kingdom of heaven and that's exactly but
With God all things are possible that
said yes this is exactly that is one of
the reasons because this guy
it's it's remarkable but but this says
to me this man is not a Christian for if
he truly believed there is nothing on
God's green earth that would have him
profess to the world of rejection of of
of his faith unless he did not have it
in the first place I mean it's hard it's
also really difficult to speak to
whether someone had it in the first
place too those aren't claims I could
make but I would say that was not the
Christian thing to do to renounce but
but look my point is this do you think
this man truly believes that when he
dies he will be judged uh that action
certainly doesn't indicate that he
believes that I can't tell you but the
action doesn't indicate he believes he
doesn't believe he'll be judged he
believes that right now in his life he
can say anything for any personal gain
if he he is a fake Christian and this is
this is an issue so many people on the
left have had with Christians for a long
time people like him who claim to be
Christians who clearly are not well no
they love Christians who are willing to
Cave into them right but they're all
arguments no I I get what you're saying
he's very valuable to the left for me
growing up so much of the complaints I
heard in cities with that there were
people who were claimed to be Christian
and then they would be the nastiest most
Cutthroat evil greedy people you've ever
met and that's exactly what that guy
Christians give Christians a bad name
off yeah and I have a an example that's
interesting I haven't really told this
so we originally we originally started
with this beer and we announced it we
had worked with a brewery in Illinois
and they had told us initially I don't
think they understood how big this would
get and so initially they said yes they
would burn the beer for us yada yada but
things were proceeding forward and they
let us know that they're very good
Christians
that they are concerned about what's
happening with all the trans stuff being
pushed on kids they're conservatives
these are things that are important to
them they believed well they believed up
until Newsweek called oh
and then
they they what's the name of the brewery
I pulled that out to make sure I did
because there's another Brewery with a
similar name I wanted to make sure I
have not listed this on anything yet so
I'm giving it to you now the correct one
it is Bent River Brewing Company
and Rock Island Illinois they were
afraid of backlash from the woke mobs
because our can I don't have it right
side up has the word conservative on it
um and they bailed on us so that's part
of it so we're we're our beer is
shipping 30 days out oh I mean if you
they put out to the media that you know
as soon as they saw our ad they they
disassociated with us that you know more
or less we're terrible people they love
everybody but there are big strong
Christians that cared about trans
ideology being pushed on kids in private
conversation and they lied they said
that they stopped working with us as
soon as they saw our ad I've got email
communication with them after so they're
scumbags and they did it under their
giant Christian name
um which is not surprising I understand
I'm making your point here with these
individuals and it is I I was I was Zero
bit shocked when it happened because
that's what I come to expect from these
kind of individuals unfortunately we
found other breweries now we got a huge
Brewery in Florida as well
how many True Believers do you think
there really are on the left
they're cognizant of their ideologies
and their methods I think it's a very
small percentage I think most of them
are just going along and getting along
and that's true of Christians as well
that's beautiful yeah yeah so when
people live in an area that's mostly
Christian they say oh of course we are
exactly then the moment the left call
say sure we're left now the golden get
along people I mean this is what people
say when they point out that if you
lived in Nazi Germany you probably
ambassadors would have turned them over
in a freaking heartbeat in a heartbeat
yeah like they can't even stand up to
saying yeah in a heartbeat they can't
handle pressure from you got some nasty
email comments or Facebook comments
because someone wants to cut dicks off
kids and your support you're making a
beer for a guy that says yeah maybe we
shouldn't do that if you can't stand up
to that I I don't I don't think you
would have done too well with the whole
Germany situation yeah yeah amen I mean
there are too many Christians who are
willing to sell out their faith and we
don't need more scared I'm gonna get a
lot of crap for this but I've said this
for years is the Evangelical Community
there there's a part of that they're out
there voting in the primaries and
they're they're hardcore but the general
Christian Community as a whole they
preach something on Sunday but they are
the ones that cave they're some of the
absolute weakest individuals when it
comes to this and I'm probably going to
get canceled for like the 48th Time by
saying this but they continue to cave
and that's again kind of
what this beer is about what we're doing
is it's encouraging people we don't have
to cave and I think the whole Bud Light
effect that you're talking about it's
conservatives are for the first time I
feel like you know you're using Target
as it as the example for the first time
I feel like conservatives are like wow
we have this power like what's this new
power let's try it out this is
interesting because I don't think they
really believed they had it prior to Bud
Light well I think that's what sold it
to them yeah I think that's true and
there's another element I'll add here
which is that we got to remember that
when it comes to Bud Light Target as
well but more so Bud Light there are
easily accessible competitors a person
doesn't really have to make many
significant changes in their life they
just buy a different brand of beer and
so that's why conservatives have to
realize that those in the movement who
would consider themselves leaders who
are go-getters have to start businesses
so that there are competing brands with
uh the big guys so that when people do
have to boycott these companies they
have somewhere else to go
because if Bud Light was the only beer
brand available I think things would
have gone differently right people had
other options it's good that we did we
need to start creating more options
Matt you think that I think that gree is
greed a sin is great so but one of the
seven deadly but getting rich is not no
getting rich is not necessary you can be
a rich Christian you know they say you
can't take your wealth with you people
that seek and grow familial wealth now
you can do a lot of good things with
money exactly you you can there's a a
rich Christian surely has to live
differently than a rich Pagan right a
rich Christian has to do more with their
money to support the church to support
the poor to help others and you know
even us has done a lot for this country
with his wealth and honestly here's
here's something I should truly thank
Elon Musk this beer company would not
exist without Elon Musk and I can say
that confidently because there's you
know we got roughly over 45 million
views on my Twitter of that ad that
would have never been allowed to happen
in the past under previous ownership and
it's also why we didn't get near those
guns views on Facebook or Instagram or
anything you know they got a lot of
views comparatively speaking but nothing
like it did on Twitter now that Elon is
kind of taken the chains off it feels
like oh sorry the Christ is like blowing
up through Elon like it's bubbling it in
him like that Christ energy the anointed
like he's been I don't know if he's been
anointed by God what if that even means
really but like he's carrying the torch
like he's doing things that will make
Humanity better off through American
ideals and I don't know what better
Christian thing you could do in the
Modern Age it's an interesting point I
think I I wouldn't uh describe it that
way theologically however I do believe
the truth is a person and that person is
Jesus Christ so when somebody is
forwarding truth they are doing
something for God in a sense right like
they're they're on the right side dude I
really maybe not in totality but you
know maybe not with everything they do
but no one particularly everything yeah
yeah yeah but but yeah so dude my point
isn't like any time anyone does
something good they are now a professing
Christian it's just to say that if
you're fighting for truth then that is a
service what you guys are saying Tim
what you brought up earlier I think
there are so many people that identify
as Christians that aren't and so many
people that identify as Jewish that
aren't just because they don't believe
in God if you don't believe like truly
believe it because I don't know if you
have to experience it to believe that
it's there but like I what we'll say
there's like 300 million Christians and
probably like point zero zero zero zero
one percent of them actually are
Christian there's there's uh 2.2 uh
billion Christians worldwide and like
probably like a hundred thousand of them
that are actually christ-like like like
yeah but you gotta remember I mean you
don't join the church for the other
Christians you join the church for
Christ because other Christians are are
gonna sin they're gonna be vicious
they're gonna fail to live up to what
they should live up to but so will you
so will all of us right it's important
to keep each other honest like without
consuming ourselves uh to to be like yo
yo like you can talk a lot of smack
about what that guy's doing wrong but if
you're not living that lifestyle of
Christ
this is what the left gets right
wielding power you win yep the
conservatives the right don't that's
what I think the I feel like the Romans
when they set up Catholicism they made
it so that it did not set up Catholicism
that's not yeah that's how it goes you
don't think so it wasn't at the Council
of nicaea 70 years after Christ's death
they no no no no so the Council of an
Ikea uh was a bit after that and this
was not um this was not set up like yes
there was Roman involvement but this is
not something the Romans ran this was
the early Christians basically making a
number of statements about their beliefs
because they're like after the time like
at the time of Christ there were just a
lot of grifters who were coming in and
making up things that had nothing to do
with Christ's teaching so then the
church had to sort this out and go like
okay what is the actual official Canon
gonna be what's going to be in the Bible
like how are we going to
um declare our faith that type of thing
but it was not the Romans who said what
concerns me is the authority of the time
that was setting it up made it seem that
like weakness is key like in order to be
a Christian you have to be weak you have
to be subservient to the authority and
like no man power does control the world
that's what you're saying Tim like the
left has understood this the power leads
and we need that in Christianity well
because the so Christians had been
persecuted for a good while before the
Council of nicer right because this is
yeah yeah this is in the 300. so this is
not like it is after I think Christ
doesn't there were multiple councils
well no the one that said well we'll
have an education on a different show
yeah yeah I guess my point is just that
the Romans did not set up Catholicism
but continue with the point that you
were making overall that power controls
everything yeah is unafraid and they're
ethos and their moral framework is there
is no truth but power and the right is
like let's all just be good stewards
yeah because Jesus was like all right if
you want to kill me go ahead
and then they killed him and it's like
no that's not what you're supposed to do
memorization well he was like at all
they came and got him and he just was
like no don't stop them how about you
stop Shifting the conversation into
arguments I'm telling you why power is
what control like but you keep shifting
it into a way that you know is going to
intentionally insult Christians no no no
but I think the reason why the right
doesn't understand that the value of
power is because Christianity has been
sold to us as if being a surf okay is
wrong is wrong no no what you're saying
is not correct
both Sheamus and Sergeant I mean said
like and those not correct and so I said
let's have an educational confidence in
religion somewhere else and get back to
the conversation about the moral
framework of the left let's move on from
yeah Mao figured it out power is what
controls Society out of the barrel of a
gun I think Mao said and uh unless these
religious folks start to understand that
I'm afraid that there will always be
coming in second well I think that truth
is more important than power and that's
the message here truth is far more
important than power it's better to have
the truth on your side than to have
power on yourself but who controls the
truth is who owns the media no the the
people that there's a reason we call
them Liars instead of saying well the
media said it so it's true
uh yeah but if you don't know they're
lying then you think it's truth and they
Define it as truth you can think
something is true but be wrong about
that
this is the this is the point with the
left
the True Believers don't care if they're
correct they say two plus two equals
five
they've they've entertained that
Prospect because when you come out and
agree with them they know they own you
if if it's it's the Star Trek how many
lights are there
there you're mistaken there are five
lights right they come to you and say
what's two plus two you say four they
say no you're wrong it's five now say it
again what's two plus two they wanna
force you to say the lie I've been
saying this for years they want to force
you say lie I refuse to say the LIE
regardless of the topic whether it's how
many genders whatever it is they just
just say it so disagree and people who
would rather die than go along with the
LIE are the biggest threat to the
establishment possible which is why they
end up being executed in tyrannical
regimes let's uh let's jump to the story
this is a big one
from TMZ Target Pride controversy bomb
threat from Angry lgbtq Ally deemed a
hoax so uh this involves us
and it happened on Friday I get a text
message asking me if it was true
and sure enough there's an email
the email says that Target is full of
swear word cowards who turned their back
on the LGBT community community and
decided to cater to the homophobic
right-wing redneck bigots blah blah blah
blah blah then says they're going to
Target a bunch of locations the email is
is listed as being sent to members at
timcast.com
we never received this email Cleveland
19 News published it we never received
that email
so I don't know where they got it from
I wonder if someone sent them a
screenshot and they like morons just
publish it yeah this is what I wanted to
ask you about because you were talking
about this over the weekend and you said
that you got a similar email but not the
same one so I'm curious why would they
make something similar and not sure the
actual one how could they have gotten
access to it no idea they could have
spoofed our email
send an email to cleveland19 but spoofed
it so that it appeared like it was sent
to us and not them but they receive it
but that just goes to show how stupid
these people are by publishing an email
that wasn't sent to them but was sent to
a different address
yeah unless the email was sent to the
most fake or Cleveland 19 actually
staged The hoax themselves
my guess is that somebody made a I mean
hey that's big news then it forces us
one of the biggest shows on live
streaming on YouTube to talk about it
well the great thing is if you're a
liberal and something it supports your
perspective you can say oh hey here's a
screenshot of an email I promise it's
really really true and send it to the
media and they'll publish it that's nuts
it's wild assume it's yeah this is the
article from Cleveland 19 news they say
Cleveland 19 News receives bomb threat
against five targets as store faces
lgbtq controversy but for some reason
they published an email that supposedly
was sent to us which we never received
so what like just photoshopped someone
photoshopped on the email address I'd
like to know what made this news
organization think it was good
journalism to publish an email that
wasn't sent to them without confirming
with us if we received it when we didn't
that's a very fair point they were just
like hey someone claims Tim pool Tim
pool's company received its email
running full
wait so do you know who reached out to
them what did they claim like a source
from no idea pools they just published
it no one from here
communicated with them and we did not
receive that email
I got a text from someone else saying is
this email real I saw it I said what
that what is this we immediately checked
this email does not exist we've never
gotten it no idea what this is
so what happens did someone email like
how is it that that Cleveland 19
received an email
uh and by the way I know we're we're
getting into the weeds but several
stores were were evacuated over this
oh so this was part of that they
immediately call the police for several
evacuations
do we have a lawsuit against them for
publishing this you know what happens in
the future now the person that's just
the kind of read the news a little bit
every now and then on a few websites
sees this and says all that Tim cast oh
that it's Fringe group of people that
was encouraging this awful you know bomb
scare at a Target and that's that's
what's forever in their head I think if
they don't no it looks like we are the
ones who reported it
it looks like we received it and alerted
the news in law enforcement
well I guess yeah you have to make a lot
of assumptions to get there I guess with
them the only assumptions you can make
here is that we received this and
forwarded it to the press and law
enforcement or to law enforcement who
gave it to the press or something like
that the email came from it alleged the
image says two members at timcast.com we
never got this the email does not exist
I don't know what this is or how they
got it so it looks fake and they ran it
the Assumption from any regular person
is going to be that we are the ones who
received it first and passed it on
that is very it's very strange it's very
very weird is this from the uh
perspective of the risk person who
received the email or from the person
that sent it looking at a draft or
received it's a complete email that says
uh from N2
so I'm curious
why didn't this company reach out to us
I mean maybe I don't know maybe they
tried and nobody answered them it was
Memorial Day weekend maybe that was the
point why would they run this story
without confirming with us first how
they received an email that was sent to
us but went to them instead yeah unless
someone sent them a picture of an email
saying hey look at this thing
that email doesn't exist yeah I'm just I
mean it's it's hard to even figure out
what their angle would be for doing
something like this
I don't know it's weird at first I
tweeted that I thought it was a hoax and
had to smear the left and the purpose of
putting our name on it was to force us
to talk about it in the show which
they've successfully done
now I think honestly
it's a possibility but the simple
solution is just the left uses violence
and threats to gain political power
by maximizing PR reach they make sure
everybody knows they will come after
that that's it interesting
that you know you like there's no reason
to smear the left by faking something
like this with a false flag because the
left literally goes on firebombs
buildings so to be clear you're saying
you do think that this is a hoax this
particular story I'm saying that I
believe the email was actually sent by a
leftist okay intending to threaten these
establishments not that they actually
it's a bomb threat hoax because they
didn't find any bombs but the real
purpose was psychological Terror from
someone who was likely on the left
trying to threaten people and say these
are the things that that they do has
Target issued any kind of statement
about this not that I'm aware yeah I
know that it was being claimed I
mentioned earlier that people who are
boycotting Target are extremists and
haven't heard too much from the left
about this yeah what a mess this email
is any reporter that had done even a
moment of thinking I would think would
be like this email was written to
someone at a Target because it's talking
about your targets doing this to your
targets except the
the the two email addresses we are
sending you a message
see that's the other thing about it it
was sent to members that allegedly sent
to members of timcast.com saying they
were sending us a message threatening us
below the addresses we will continue to
the email says wow yeah well just your
teamwork is what are they talking about
like they're sending it to a Target
administrator if they're saying your
targets they're talking about but it's
the email address is not a Target email
address so pretty much some left just
drank too much Bud Light one night rode
this email sent it off and it got
reported as real no it's more
sophisticated than that it's because
they would have had to have spoofed our
email and then dropped the email so they
would have had to have used some kind of
spoofing so that it went to Cleveland 19
but used our email address instead which
is not a simple feat it's not the most
complicated feat but the average
person's not gonna be able to do it
you're not you're not some random left
to slam in a Bud Light and then doing
this you're you're some hacker or
someone with a general knowledge on how
to spoof email addresses or BCC because
I think the BCC the blind did not
receive the email meaning it never went
to us which means it was a spoof so
unless Cleveland 19 themselves made the
fake email intentionally to get news for
this well also we just have a screenshot
here right yeah it's extremely easy to
just inspect element in your browser
type in a fake email address under from
so they wouldn't even have to be able to
spoof an email address right honestly I
wouldn't be surprised if somebody worked
at Cleveland 19 fabricated the email
this is what they published the quality
is super low you can see like the little
outlines inside those it's look that's
like what uh shame is saying it could be
done very easily within the browser just
inspect edit the text and then it just
it looks so bad you can just tell it
doesn't look like it's
yeah I don't know seems fake yeah yeah I
mean I have no idea who faked it or why
like I said it's a very strange thing
I'm trying to figure out the motivation
but I mean I think Tim's right I think
they're just trying to make it seem that
like we will come after you we will make
this a thing and again they like
literally too much saying a second ago
might is right to them they believe that
the power is is everything so having the
power to then show we will use this
power is everything
confusion man here's the other thing I
tweeted that this email is not real on I
think the 27th and they've not done
anything they don't like CBS 19 or
Cleveland who's the name yeah and other
people were like sharing the link being
like yo Tim pools like they don't have
this email it's not a real email and
they don't care that's why I'm like I
think maybe they did it right yeah as
Credence or maybe there's a leftist who
works there who fabricated the email put
our name on it to generate a bunch of
attention knowing that it'll spark
controversy yeah yeah it could be a two
there you go I don't know man but they
ended up evacuating a a bunch of
different Target shops all those Ohio
stores that they were listed on there no
these are Utah
which is yeah very far away which is
really odd
it's very weird yeah how far away is
that Ohio place that's like we're a
couple hours away Ohio is about five and
a half hour drive from here yeah those
locations all right oh those locations
yeah they can't that's like where I went
to college yeah it's pretty far away
yeah Utah Utah is even further it's like
at least right 22 hours drive so so the
emails that we got were different
kind of like the idea was similar and it
listed the name of other prominent
culture War individuals and so I'm like
like the the email thread was sent to
various people and I'm like okay this is
weird but I I think it's it's a spoof
it's not real
yeah someone if there's some there's
some degree of sophistication the
question is who did it was it a leftist
actually targeting these doors that's
Pro Occam's razor suggests was it but
then here's the question right because
you mentioned you did get an email that
was similar but not the same as this one
so how could the news network have
spoofed it if they had no idea that you
got a similar email like that's what's
weird about it to me is you did get a
similar email that they're the ones who
did it I don't know oh they're the ones
who sent you the initial email but then
wanted to show the actual email I have
no idea
modeling they're they're muddling people
have muddled the conversation rather
than building another beer brand we're
talking about what confused us yesterday
Fair Point dude that's a war like that
you want people turning in circles
someone in chat said Jesse Smollett yeah
all right well let's just hard shift
into World War Three now and we'll talk
about this we have this story from NBC
News this is kind of crazy drone strikes
hit Moscow in first attack on Russian
Russia's Russian capitals residential
areas since Ukraine War Began once again
no one knows exactly who's responsible
Russia of course says it's the Kiev
regime attacking civilian targets while
the West says that it's a Russian false
flag intended to bolster public support
for war in Russia here's why I think
that's less likely the attack was on a
wealthy area of Moscow if you attack
poor people you generate support for war
if you attack rich people the rich
people come after rich people in The
Establishment Elite say like hey stop
this our wealth is being destroyed
because of it it's also possible the
idea to take the rich people because the
rich people will then be like we want
war now but the rich
people were always part of the regime
the political establishment in Russia so
they're typically in line already yeah
that's a good point I mean if the elite
are gonna pull off some kind of false
flag it would make much more sense for
them to go after people who are lower
status and don't have as much power to
fight back against them
yeah world war three hmm
um
I don't know I think that uh what our
entire media needs to do is speak about
this as aggressively as possible without
considering the consequences
what do you mean not being I'm being
facetious because that's what they've I
mean that's what they've been doing
right we were talking about this earlier
when Lindsey Graham like a year and a
half ago got on the BBC and literally
called for Putin's assassination I mean
people will come after figures in New
Media for saying something slightly
offensive and say well these content
creators just aren't responsible enough
I mean
an American politician was on television
calling for the assassination of the
leader of a nation which is armed with
nuclear weapons and that was just
allowed to happen yeah I think it's I
mean we've uh the the media and
political classes rhetoric surrounding
this has been insanely irresponsible
thank you responsible it's important to
be responsible even right now us talking
about this because there's a lot of
people listening and this is like
sensitive you know I I don't think it's
a false flag but then a dozen or so
drones
attacked civilians drone Warfare 21st
century Warfare we see the tip of the
spear right now
attack civilians I think it makes sense
that Kiev did this more so than Russia
false flagged it or some could even been
so independent if Russia was going to do
it right trying to Fan the Flames of war
between all factions yeah but I feel
like if Russia was going to do a false
flag they wouldn't Target their Elites
and it would be more sophisticated than
a few drones that failed to do any real
damage yeah the real issue I think is
that Kiev wants to send Terror to the
civilians and destabilize public opinion
definitely I think that's what it is
it's also like kind of a tip or tat
thing because they've been shelling
different parts of like Ukraine as well
including the attacker I don't think
it's tit for Tad I think it's more so
you want to force the enemy to retreat
to start you put them put them on
defense instead of offense but if this
is legitimate attack or whether or not
even if it's not I think we're now
moving very seriously close towards a
nuclear war because Vladimir Putin said
he would use nukes if there was an
existential threat to Russia and now
Russian civilians are being attacked and
the United States has done nothing to
promote diplomacy he's not going to lose
that war right he has nukes and he's not
the kind of guy that's like well I would
win but I just don't want to use my news
it's not how it works dude when when the
when the USSR fell with the United
States promised is that we would not
expand NATO an inch Eastward and all we
have done is expand NATO Eastward in
that entire time and
I'm not saying what Putin has done is by
any means good but what I am saying is
our failure to behave diplomatically on
the global stage
Bears some responsibility for What's
Happening Here Right you can't just put
this all on crazy bad Russian man dude
the United States had a duty to behave
responsibly on the foreign stage and we
consistently have not I remember
watching like maybe like almost 10 years
ago
um I think it might have been like a
vice vice piece I don't remember what it
was but I was watching years and years
ago uh it was Putin speaking saying like
the West is aggressing the West has all
these new positions outside of out of
Russia now and that that's only born to
be true now that he's actually in the
situation that we are in the situation
it's just
yeah it's it's so weird it's so weird
that we that we are finally here the
engineers since then so do you think
this is like a fold over of fear of like
the of the the Soviet Union like like no
I'm not blaming Hillary like whoever but
like people from that generation are
like they're actually afraid of a of the
Soviet Union communism in Ukraine many
people are yeah well I think that what
this I mean
Russia is in the 20th century faced what
two up to this point three serious
existential crises in the United States
and Germany has been involved with all
of them and so NATO which is basically
the United States and Germany starts
inching closer and closer towards
Russia's borders I mean there was no
sensitivity on our part in saying okay
even if our intentions are good let's
pretend that they were and we can
guarantee that our intentions were good
maybe we need to be very careful and
sensitive about how we go about this so
that a hot war between Russia and
Ukraine doesn't begin but
no we did what we did we we mercilessly
ridiculed and insulted Russia throughout
the entirety of Trump's presidency
because the media wanted to scapegoat
somebody for Trump's election and they
couldn't just directly hate on the
American people because that would be
bad for their Optics yeah I think if
anything that might have been born of
people that were born in like the the
area of the Cold War they were they
wanted to blame Russia Russia seem as if
they were still the Soviet Union when in
reality it's it's far from the case you
know well in remember back in 2012 when
Mitt Romney
of course it was Mitt Romney said that
Russia was going to be one of the
primary existential threats to the
United States in coming years and
everyone laughed at him and now
everyone's agreeing with him we should
have kept laughing at him right and I
know people are saying how could you
argue that when Russia is in a hot war
with Ukraine right now part of the
reason Russia is in a hot war with
Ukraine right now is because the United
States has been Reckless and it there's
this idea of speaking softly and
carrying a big stick
what the United States has done is we
have we've spoken very loudly about a
lot of these things when you've spoken
very inappropriately about them what was
interesting about Donald Trump is even
though to some extent he kept the peace
didn't start any new Wars uh Putin
didn't invade while Trump was President
he waited until there was a man with
dementia in the Oval Office before he
decided to invade uh when Trump was in
office there's a good argument he made
that in some sense he was
he was very heavy-handed with Putin in
terms of the threats he made to him at
least according to what Trump has said
what happened was Trump knew that in
order to
guarantee the peace even though
diplomacy was necessary there were
moments where harshness was also
necessary the big red button had to work
and well yeah and there is something
about that and there is something about
the fact that Biden in the left they
either have no idea where those lines
are or they just don't care and I I
suspect it's the latter yeah I think so
they like Trump's had the big stick but
he he spoke loudly but he had the big
stick Biden speaks loudly but he's got a
wet noodle
I think I think there's truth in that
but I also think like it depends on how
we're defining speed speaking loudly
because even though Trump look he had a
lot of nerve he walked right into North
Korea to me with Kim Jong-un this is a
guy who while he was being even somewhat
Brash and abrasive was still pursuing
peace like even when he was allowed he
was still pursuing peace he wanted to
find a diplomatic solution to these
problems he wasn't interested in just
going around and bullying other
countries speaking of Peace do you
remember the Kindle I think it's Kendall
Jenner uh ad the Pepsi ad yes
he can goes over to the Riders
everyone's happy in love I think all
this Russia talk what we really need is
we need Donald Trump zielinski and Putin
and Trump needs to deliver an ultra
right is that your next commercial I
think so I think we've just developed
that on air oh
have you noticed that it's really hard
to find people to work yes I have and I
think this is a a the result of an eight
so people have said that a lot of people
retired it's like where so uh we have
the racetrack over here Charlestown
Races and they used to have a restaurant
we asked them how come there's no
restaurant at the horse track anymore
and say we can't find anybody to work
everybody retired they say we can't open
any more poker tables we got no dealers
where the dealers go they were they were
tired where are the people who are
working they say nobody's working
anymore the younger generation won't
work 100 imagine what it's going to be
like in this country in 20 years it's
gonna be bad my kids are going to rule
the roost because they will work a bunch
of leftists who won't work are going to
show up with pitchforks and see all
their stuff yeah there's that usually
you end up conscripting people if you
have a society of uneducated or
unemployed uh what just leads you to
desperation which means you can script
them into the military to do some crazy
aggressive conquering War to get the
resources that you weren't producing
these kids today are not doing any
conquering of anything to be clear the
ones that are not working
and it depends right because when
there's a shortage of people
you can't afford war in quite the same
way you look at what's happening in
China I think that's far more concerning
they had a policy of aborting young baby
girls and also engaging in open and
fantaside and so now the men
have a lopsided ratio there are more men
there by women by a non-insignificant
margin so what do we have we have a
bunch of young men who there are no
women for what do we do with them you
know the United States talks a lot in
our our politicians talk a lot about the
quote unquote like in-cell problem
they have an entire population of people
for whom there literally are no women
available and everyone knows that
unmarried young men as a demographic are
dangerous so maybe you cook up a word
ago send them to fight and to call that
herd maybe you tell them if you invade
this other country you can have the
women there yeah it's so wild to think
no I'm serious
human beings I mean history did not end
despite what the Marxist or
neoconservatives as you believe I think
people think all right this is this is
them there are no these young people
that are not working are not gonna go
fight Wars I'm not talking about here
I'm talking about China yeah I'm talking
about those places that's that's that's
not happening yeah I don't know man I I
think China is a serious threat I okay
we can talk about the China thing it's
an economic threat and they're they're
winning that threat that's a whole
nother thing they don't want China
doesn't want to attack us because we're
their their cash register so that's a
whole whole other scenario but I think
the problem back to the young people
that don't work there's a lot of
problems there but yeah and that's
that's also in China too like I think
they have Tung ping in China which is
just lying flat which is meaning like
you just they people just don't work
they just don't they literally don't
work they won't stay home there's also a
massive problem of not only people not
working but again so I was talking about
China's demographic in fact they have a
large male population which is a
frightening thing right but also the
fact that here the massive problem we're
facing and I think one that most
developed nations are going to be facing
between the next 20 and 40 years is
exactly this we didn't uh populate at
acquitted adequate enough numbers yeah
right for there to be um a a legitimate
in well-functioning Workforce and
economy in the future I mean my goodness
what is it Social Security right now
it's something like for people working
for every one retiree I think I think
the ratio is even worse than that at
this point it's not it's not just it's
just it's not just Social Security but
my point is that's indicative of a much
broader problem not just lack of
reproduction which is a big factor
though it's that gen Z and Millennials
typically don't work yeah they don't
want to work they don't want to do a job
they don't have jobs yeah they don't
want look man we've been trying to build
this new facility for so long and it's
insane how hard it is to find people to
do any amount and by the way these in
cells and all these guys that aren't
getting girls and all this kind of
that we hear about all the time
is if these guys like got off their ass
and maybe went to the gym and stopped
eating crap all the time and actually
look there's tons of women out there
that would love a decent presenting guy
there's just not a total dumb ass
sitting around playing video games all
the time so that is a very solvable
problem but it's it's it's it's not for
lack of or it is for it's a for a lack
of trying and many other and knowing a
lot of people don't realize the value of
being healthy when it comes to selecting
I agree with that because I've been lied
to by the government for decades now
about health like people think that if
they can laugh and joke their way to
getting a mate it's just not you got to
be I mean you might be able to if you're
the funniest guy on Earth but like if
you're not physically fit man good luck
yeah you got to take care of your body
present you got to be a protector and
you need to have good good genes and
those genes can deteriorate over time if
you feed them crap
very quickly yeah true it's time to have
kids you got kids I do you are great
kids you are thought conservative dad
that that is true okay TM we're
trademarking it
but yeah I do have two great kids and
they will work when they're older if I
have kids yeah I mean it's it's oh sorry
they're going to be the age of my
friend's grandkids oh my God like the
kids friends that I went to high school
with and stuff they all have kids one
with his kids 22. like my kids will be
his grandson's age it's so wild yeah
that's right I'm sorry no no I mean just
to kind of jump onto this point it's
it's a both hand right it's it's a
massive issue because you're correct
that a lot of young people don't want to
work that's also compounded by the fact
that there are just fewer young people
we I mean we're not making Replacements
things are really gonna I mean they're
still not working that makes it worse
a smaller pool but we have a problem
with the young people we have right yeah
so we're gonna so we're getting rid of
all the jobs young people typically
worked like fast food restaurants we're
now using robots you see those robots
that make the cheeseburgers yeah now
they're just you're gone you go to
McDonald's is a vending machine at this
point
here's the issue though we need plumbers
we need Carpenters we need special
mechanics mechanics yeah it's huge nope
I need somebody who knows how to do
concrete can we find them nope nope
we're going on two years trying to build
this building and get everything set up
a job that normally would be done in
like six weeks and we we were going
through different Crews it's insane and
of course everybody says the same thing
like oh we will do it and then they show
up and say we can't find anybody yep
yeah man uh I remember when that
pipeline was hacked about two years ago
and nobody there knew how to work the
manual system because all the people who
could use it retired out I mean wow
that's just the entire economy right now
I think the unemployment has something
to do with it because right now you're
incentivized to not work if you're
collecting unemployment you're getting a
thousand bucks a week or every two weeks
or whatever it is if you get a job you
lose that thousand bucks every two weeks
so if you're gonna make 900 every two
weeks at your job you're actually making
less working 40 hour 80 hours than you
are sitting on your ass that needs to be
inverted you need to firstly this is why
I like Ubi because you don't lose it
when you get a job you shouldn't lose
your unemployment employment when you
get a job we're just like a wild turn
did you say Ubi that's part of what I
like about Ubi in regard like as a swap
out for unemployment because you don't
lose your Ubi when you get a job in fact
maybe you shouldn't get unemployment
unless you yeah I would just instantly
destroy the system overnight yeah it's
not a it's not effective you need to
make the Joe Rogan transition on the Ubi
thing I said no yes he was original for
it he said that covid watching the coven
handouts completely changed his opinions
the Ubi stuff won't work yeah well he's
he he's he's now listening he literally
yeah 100 he was serious went into a
whole thing about it he was like the
covet after seeing how the handouts and
how people responded to that he realized
it will not work people will not work if
you give them right money to sit at home
the ubis it's all completely insane well
but there is this bizarre sort of
roussoian appeal to man's better nature
that even if he's getting money to do
nothing he's still going to go do
something it's like okay well maybe
maybe he does do something and it's
stupid and we don't need it and it
doesn't benefit anybody here's what I
said to my friends how many of how here
I'll ask you Seth how many how many
people do you know play guitar
play the guitar maybe a handful at most
you only know a handful I mean I
probably know a lot that I don't even
realize I play guitar well also uh
Champions you know a lot of people like
guitar I know a couple people who play
guitar probably how many people out of
them do you think they would want to
make a living playing guitar
I know one that tried very hard
are they good enough to make a living
playing guitar
um he did okay see I always ask this to
my Lefty friends how many people you
know play the guitar on the I don't know
a bunch and I'll be like
do they want to make a living doing it
like well yeah like they want to be rock
stars are they good enough and they go
no yeah and I'm like so if you gave them
Ubi guess what they would do instead of
working yep they would just go and play
the guitar they're not very good at it
yeah 100 that sums up everything right
there maybe you could do perfect
unemployment that doesn't you don't lose
it when you get a job at least well
that's what they have right now with all
this coveted stuff that they still could
go work jobs and still be getting the
Kobe money they could have more or less
double dipped and a lot of them just
refuse to go work yeah yeah definitely
they could have doubled they could be
doing that there's still a state I think
malice Michael malice did someone on the
show about all of this it was pretty
interesting the wrong person this is
this is this is the issue work does not
exist work is not a thing
the idea of work is nonsense and we need
to stop saying it when I wake up and I
quote unquote work I'm not at work yeah
like I come in here I read the news and
then I get feelings I want to talk about
I read the things and I want to do it I
do the stuff that I want to do yeah
these people don't want to do anything
at all right so to them anything they
don't want to do is work yes the problem
is they are blank slates it used to be
that when you were a kid you'd watch
your parents do their thing you'd learn
from them
you know we were driving in the car
recently with some with some friends and
uh someone mentioned they used to have a
dream and they wake up at school you
know I have a dream while I'm in school
naked or something and then we always
hear uh people say like I have these
weird dreams which like I forgot to turn
in a test but I'm like I'm like 35 man
like what I'm not in school anymore and
I said it's because human beings are not
supposed to spend half their life
in an institutionalized learning
facility and then overnight switch Yeah
to something totally different
so what happens is all of your
developmental years are in this machine
so now
20 years later you have a nightmare
about forgetting a test because your
body and mind have been trained and
conditioned to do that 100 if we grew up
on farms
you'd be 15 you'd have you'd have a
nightmare you forgot to to get the eggs
from that from the from the chicken coop
yeah then when you're 35 you wake up and
go I've got the eggs oh uh I didn't
forget the eggs it wouldn't be out of
place because your life stays the same
the issue now is I said this 20 years
ago to a friend of mine
she told me she didn't know what she
wanted to do with her life she was like
20 something she was close to finishing
college and I was like what were you
doing when you were 13 and she was like
hanging out with my friends I don't know
riding bikes and I said you want to open
a bar and she went oh my God that would
be amazing and I'm like yeah when you
were a kid your whole day was hanging
out with your friends shooting a
talking about stuff you want to open a
bar because then you can hang out all
day talk hang out with your friends
shooting the yeah right the kids
who grew up to be pro baseball players
they were playing baseball when they
were five years old exactly they're 13
years old they're playing baseball
they're 40 years old they're playing
baseball
it's not work now here's the thing I
still say I have to work like because I
have a schedule because I have
responsibilities but doing this all the
stuff we do it's not like oh yeah sorry
guys I've got I've got an eight to two
eleven yeah you know well for sure
people have gotta you gotta Channel it
into work your work needs to be if you
want to do it well and be successful at
it it needs to be something that you
love that doesn't mean you're not going
to have mundane aspects of it you know
and and that we all understand but
overall in general you've got to feel
like what you're doing is accomplishing
something whether it's fixing someone's
car and you wanting to see someone you
know roll out with a working vehicle or
you want to see someone walking home
with food that magically ends up in the
grocery store those kinds of things you
gotta have some incentive behind it and
you got to have some you know actual
motivation and love for what you're
doing I think the issue is
we we institutionalized all of our
children we took away child labor child
labor is a very very good thing we just
don't want kids in factories and in Coal
Mines right we want them at coffee shops
and paper routes exactly children doing
work is a good thing and beer factories
that's it but
work yep working at the fan Fanny
grocery store was work working on the
farm was work walking the dog walking
the dogs my six-year-old legit asked me
I guess it was last week or the week
before he said Dad I want to do a
lemonade stand this summer and if you
know me you kind of know I love hearing
my six-year-old say that I'm also
thinking where the hell we can do a
lemonade stand I was like where are we
going to do this well any names oh
downtown it's an area near where we live
well that's pretty good there's a lot of
people there and he said yeah I'm going
to sell lemonade and Ultra right beer
yeah he's ready so did he fire off the
lemonade stand or is that coming up well
this was like a week or two ago so he
they just got out of school last week
awesome awesome we'll figure out
something good deals make set up a good
deal maybe cheap cheap refills yeah I
can see that why don't you launch a
lemonade company and you can have your
kid on it I like the idea my kids do
work for me and I pay them when they
work for me
um I I am a bit busy with beer for a
lemonade company and uh I think I'm
starting but you have your kid do it
there's a lot to sourcing this much
product of anything and shipping liquid
I don't know how you pull that off oh a
lot so it's the whole product just
getting cans right now aluminum cans uh
that are not made by the devil I mean
bush is is difficult and finding people
to work to put sleeves on the cans by
the way the company that this is a
perfect example the company that put the
sleeves on our can one of the biggest
issues we had we got all the sleeves
printed everything ready to go I don't
have staff to do it I don't have staff
to do it you know and that's something
we ran into and we kind of run into that
same issue along the way in a lot of
places throughout this
um but yeah it's it's a lot of it's a
lot of work a lot of we got Dane we got
coffee and we want to do cold brew
because I love cold brew that's my jam
right and so we've reached out to our
suppliers or Distributors our companies
and it would cost us we would have to
sell the can of cold brew per can five
dollars per cold brew what kind of
overhead is that that basically makes us
baby alive margins no no you're not yeah
are you um is it what what is what are
you being told is the major cost in that
shipping liquid
well no but okay but is that because
no you should talk to me about this is
it so they're saying that five dollars
per can like because the coffee itself
like you know you got very minimal
ingredients there obviously so all all
this how bulk are you looking at
we like so we're not gonna be putting in
millions of dollars to order big
warehouses full you wouldn't have to but
like if you did a tractor trailer loads
where you really get your main discount
when it comes to like uh aluminum so
we're all online and we want to do
online sales and we did all of the uh
all the sourcing and everything and it
would come out to like breaking even at
five bucks a can
so it's just we're avoiding it for now
yeah I think you actually can find out
you you could do this too and because
you
dealing with coffee you have so many
more options than we are with alcohol so
UPS is
some will ship within certain more or
less you can over if I summed it up you
could say UPS is really the only one
that will ship alcohol but you can ship
your coffee with USPS as much as they
suck a lot of the times but nonetheless
you can ship your coffee with that so
you can have a lot cheaper options of
getting your uh liquid to people
pipeline Yeah
Tim this is not the right time we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at dimcast.com because we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
for you just after this one so around 10
or so p.m on the front page of
timcast.com you don't want to miss it
all right cold Deluxe production says
hey Tim heads up but Nebraska recently
passed school choice and a pro-life Bill
the state keeps getting more red
very interesting graft D of course has
buck buck very nice crafty waffle Sensei
says Tim can we talk about Dylan
Mulvaney coming out as straight that was
an old video and Dylan Mulvaney was
saying that trans women are women not
that Dylan Mulvaney is attracted to
females
yeah that's why he said no she will get
me pregnant because he's first of all
it's a Borat like bit because he can't
get pregnant but he was saying that uh
that he's talking about trans women and
so I went to my dad and said I'm
attracted to women and my dad said wow
and then I said haha I'm talking about
trans women Bob and that's that's the
gag
all right Raymond G7 says Tim it's
unofficially official my dude the Bud
Light effect is now in the urban
dictionary for all to reference
companies companies need to fear the Bud
Light effect
well all right all right
GD says hashtag believe all women we
didn't get to that we'll talk about that
I suppose in the members only the uh
Tara Reid fleeing to Russia excellent
he's a little adult
Brandon Smith has got my Appalachian
nights order today excited to try it by
the way Southern West Virginia better
than the Panhandle we were hanging out
in Charleston West Virginia again that
was yeah that was amazing we went to
um we drove like an hour and a half into
the mountains to get ice cream and you
guys walked up a hill like I don't know
we climbed a mountain a thousand feet up
the mountain I don't know about a
thousand 500 feet up the mountain maybe
500 feet you were becoming tiny specks
in the distance the next kind of scary
was super Steep and it just rained and
were really dumb so we got out of our
cars in the middle of nowhere in a
mountain where like the only people were
on ATVs and motorbike like uh dirt bikes
and then we climbed up this super steep
like it was very steep is it Rock
s like dirt yeah gravel and then a
couple rock smash so in Georgia we have
a place called Stone Mountain it's the
world's largest
single piece of granite that you could
climb it's like actual mountain and
every year a few people do what you just
did and they oh geez right down well
this was does not work out well this is
mud and grass
for the most part yeah and so like a
beaten Trail slime down a little bit was
fun the only the only thing bad about it
was that it just rained it rained like
several hours earlier so it was wet but
uh you know it wasn't where we weren't
mountain climbing we weren't like yeah
we were walking up a hill well that's
the way that's the way something is they
close it when it rains for that reason
so just saying you could have been like
people scraping in the grass or
something they slip and then of the edge
but there's no Edge oh you don't have an
okay no no it was a big hill all right
so we just went out walked up and walked
down like you get to the top and you're
just it's flat okay yeah it was but it
was cool though we just you know climb
up that for no reason more like Hills
Noah Sanders says Tim I'd love to open a
cast Brew franchise that doubles as a
comedy club at night do you think
there's any way to secure a liquor
license to the franchise we can sell
Seth's beer during stand-up uh I mean
let's do it let's figure out how to do
it we're still working on the first
location and it's taking forever
is there any it's insane how long it
takes to do anything is there any
process for people to start setting up
franchises yet we can until we have
everything set up and we have
I mean it's it's Bonkers I got an email
about it so uh we'll be sending at some
point I'm sure like franchise uh dude
nobody's working I'm sorry it's just
it's just that's just it there's nobody
working and I've been saying over and
over again every other week when I get
angry and angrier because we're now two
years on from this new location not
being done because nobody is working and
I'm like do we have to drive to Home
Depot and just offer people jobs like
tell me what to do tell me how ask them
nobody nobody it's it's the most insane
thing I'll be like bro how much money
you want like I don't want to work as
well I'm like holy crap dude I spend the
day on the phone trying to get something
done that required some manual labor and
knowledge mechanic wise I mean you know
my girlfriend can tell you I was just in
the car non-stop calling place after
place and we don't have anybody that can
do it we just don't have the Manpower I
mean we've literally heard that prop not
exaggerating probably 30 times just on
the Manpower no one knows how to do that
anymore don't have the Manpower how are
people living
I don't know man that's crazy I just
don't get it with their parents yup on
unemployment and and not wanting to work
they just refuse to do any work they're
nihilistic lazy angry I'm not saying all
at once I'm saying one person's
nihilistic one person's lazy one
person's angry one person's ego is too
big I I this work is beneath me it's
like yeah exactly like I will pay you
whatever you want to do this job just
please come and do it I would do it
myself but I'm doing this job and
they're like no it's beneath me I'm like
okay well no so you know what I've said
we're getting really close to the point
where I'm like I'm just going to Tweet
the address and tell people to show up
it's well hey that might work yep yep
here's the address show up we want this
done we'll provide the tools we've got a
bunch of cashiers checks ready to go
just slipping them out we'll sign your
name to it right now at the end of the
day don't give those out early I mean
this is one of the massive problems
there are a number of problems with this
but this is one of the massive problems
with the government deciding to get
involved in the economy pick winners and
losers and say the wave of the future is
going to be people being employed based
on having a four to six year college
degree so now we're going to subsidize
these loans not only has it trained
people and pushed people into Fields
where there isn't as much demand as it
was once speculated there would be not
only is it increase the cost of loans
but it takes people out of the workplace
for four to six years as well yes
totally it's just the weirdest thing to
me that people wouldn't mind running
around killing boars for three hours and
then going to the quartermaster for a
new quest to go kill Griffins and then
they're like after killing a thousand of
them I've gotten enough gold to buy the
forest leather boots of agility and I'm
like bro get a job
I don't understand how that
like oh yeah dude you don't feel that
same way when you finally acquire your
new Legend of Zelda like I've gone to my
quest Master my boss and said what tasks
need be done and then he says You must
deliver 16 bags of french fries and
you're like I will do it then you run
around handing out french fries and then
he gives you your quest reward and
people are not do you know what they
have to do they have to put VR headsets
on people that are actually just goggles
like South Park and tell them it's a
video game look at his McDonald's
I hate all of this I just want to be
clear I was very angry at the rental car
I had doesn't have a stick shift like I
was like this it's it's it's gone too
far so I saw my girlfriend she's like
you're not gonna do well I've
experienced this phenomena where people
in video games will play for 100 hours
to get the items they want in the game
100 hours of their time and but where at
the same time it only costs about 500
worth of money to get the thing they
spend 100 hours if you work for a
hundred hours you're gonna have way more
than five hundred dollars you can buy
this stuff
but the the idea that you don't have to
pay you don't have to play to win you
can pay to win and you can get a job
that pays more than the amount like time
is money how many casinos are popping up
that's terrible in general so let me let
me tell you right now near us we have
Charlestown if we drive one hour just
one hour East there are three you've got
so there's there's Charlestown which is
right here then you've got Horseshoe in
Baltimore Maryland Live Baltimore MGM
Grand DC if you drive an hour and a half
north you've got Hollywood Harrisburg
Hollywood York if you drive about two
hours West you have uh Rocky Gap if you
I'm sorry no that's about an hour and a
half Rocky Gap if you drive two hours
you've got Lady Lady Luck I think it's
called if you drive two and a half hours
if you drive one more hour past
Baltimore you've got the Delaware race
tracks so that's nine and I feel like
I'm probably forgetting one
you also have Pittsburgh which is two
and a half hours from here which has
where are they getting their money to
spend three hours from here is Atlantic
City and Philadelphia live and rivers So
within a few hours driving let's just
say three hours to our cap you've
probably got 15 casinos
the craziest thing is MGM Grand
and well I mean honestly and Horseshoe
the question always arises everyone I
talk to they say I don't know where
these people have money yeah that's what
I mean bro this is this is what's
freaking me out because I because I hang
out at the poker tables right poker's
300 bucks to buy in and you can play for
all day and leave with three hundred
dollars people think poker is like you
go in there you're like I bet it all and
you lose right that's not the game is
very slow you get your cards for free
it's not a poker table before the big
blind comes a deal you cards you get to
play the game you don't got to spend any
money you could pay two dollars at the
low stakes games just for fun to hang
out but I go out to the floor at MGM one
hand of say like four card poker it's a
table game 250 dollars
losing a middle class is what's
happening yeah
I think you've got people well I mean
there's you know you've got people that
have a lot of money and you've got you
know again that Gap is widening yeah and
so the people with a lot of money
blowing 250 bucks or whatever it is
at the grocery store and we spent about
180 bucks on all these groceries and I
sat down and as I was getting into the
car the thought came into my mind it's
good to be rich I just thought it and I
was like how many people because I just
went in swiped a piece of plastic and
got all this food I was like wow how
many people just live like that they're
like I'm just gonna keep my mouth shut
and suck off the system because I happen
to be one of the rich ones and not
mention like where are they
intentionally silent they're
intentionally camouflaging this is all
these crypto wealthy people that made
millions in the last 10 years uh all
this new currency because yeah we have
35 trillion in American dollar debt all
this crypto trillions I don't know so
yeah out of zero two trillion so that's
another form of inflation they're just
silent they don't want to get taxed on
it they don't want the government to
know they have it they're you know yeah
that's a big one
I think that before we get to the
metaverse era where people detach from
reality we'll be in the casino era when
people don't need like here's what will
happen if Ubi becomes a thing I
guarantee you people will just spend all
day at the casino yeah yeah they'll be
like I need 200 bucks for my food
Casino time right because they got
nothing else to do and the money's
coming back anyways it doesn't matter if
they have to work they know the money is
guaranteed you'll notice in some casinos
a lot of retirees yeah and the Trope of
the the customer is a guy who retired
who gets several hundred bucks per week
or is you know a certain portion of his
budget he just goes to the casino
because the money's coming and people
often say I was reading a meme about
poker and I was like God bless the old
man who shows up and loses his money
every week and then someone responded I
don't think you understand this old man
just wants to hang out with you yeah
yeah like 100 so you're getting their
pension money
but that's what people are going to turn
into when they no longer have to work
when food is abundant when everything's
automated they're going to go gamble
um that is depressing
I'm not arguing with you I'm just saying
it's depressing it is insane how many
casinos there are just everywhere
popping up it's like if you live in if
you live north of DC you're within 45
minutes of three major casinos not only
that that's crazy it's online gambling
too online gambling has been exploding
so yeah that's also true it's massive
right now and there's really weird
online gambling too where it's like the
Heavy's in the Plinko one yeah yeah
that's Plinko is like the the Japanese
is that right it's a it's a it's a
pyramid-shaped pegs yeah you bet money
the money falls down and if it hits hits
the the far sides it multiplies the
money by huge numbers in the middle it's
like times one or times half people are
playing weird gambling games online they
have nothing to do but my question is
like where do any of these people get
money from like I just don't I don't
know man don't get it dude I do not
understand this I go to the casino and
I'll beat the crab stable as a guy with
10 grand sitting there I'm like what is
what does he do
like that's crazy to me and some people
always say like oh well maybe it's just
credit or they shouldn't be gambling the
money and then I'm like if that were
true I would all I would not also be
asking where are the people who are who
are like where are the workers are they
all just homeless you know these people
want jobs no I don't know man who knows
all right let's read some more
Gabriel Lopez says sorry to inform they
won't go broke corporations don't need
customers in our Fiat system they have a
good CEI score and BlackRock fed will
give them infinite free money with zero
interest and they will weather the storm
they can only go broke if they don't go
woke so you're probably a Dei score you
said CEI oh yeah Dei he said CEI that's
part of it where are they getting the
money and well it's Fiat here's a good
one ten times what you have drew
outstanding in Fields as in honor of the
Fallen I'm matching all super chats
about Memorial Day up to one thousand
dollars on this episode giving to a
veteran org that supports children of
service members who made the ultimate
sacrifice retired army Sergeant
all gave some some gave all it's the
least I can do that's really amazing
dude I really do appreciate that so I
think to clarify what you're saying is
for people who make Memorial Day super
chats here you will donate to a charity
supporting the children of veterans
you're legit true yeah
thanks dude kid truck says hey did you
guys hear about the bus driver who got
fired from Charlotte Area Transit System
when a passenger pulled a gun on him and
he defended himself they fired him
because they have a no weapons policy oh
my guess they think you should just get
shot well there was the guy in the
parking garage who got shot twice
wrestled the gun away from the guy and
then shot in self-defense and then they
were like you're under arrest these
people need to gotta get these dangerous
people off the streets Tim where was
that was that a New York thing I think
that was a New York thing yeah I think
you're right what that prosecutors
should be in jail absolutely incredible
when you've got Christians on TV like
denouncing their faith yeah I don't
think
oh I know they're not going to jail I
just said they should be well to be fair
denouncing your faith is one of the
requirements to being a Christian on TV
yeah there you go
what do we got crooked smells that I
remember a campaign in another country
with the Burger King mascot sharing a
passionate kiss with Ronald McDonald it
was ridiculous wait what oh the Burger
King guy wait a minute are you talking
about the Hamburglar no the no that's
McDonald's yeah
King Burger King the Burger King that
was a really dumb idea let's make our
mascot a king who runs around dude he's
horrifying he is he is legitimately
terrifying it's also quite horrifying
about uh
the the mayor mcchees's head is made of
dead cow meat
his head is he's like a bizarre
Frankenstein's monster oh the king
Joel draws it says Tim is wrong about
Chick-fil-A he is bsing to stay in the
argument it's a safer place to take your
kids and it is slammed with moms Monday
through Friday I did not say it was not
safe I did not say that uh it wasn't
slammed with moms so what what am I not
be asking to say in the conversation do
you think I'm wrong about your own show
my experience in the drive through being
the drive-through being overloaded dude
there's no argument the drive foot
Chick-fil-A is always full whether or
not you're okay with it you've had a
good experience it's different from my
experience my experience with Taco Bell
is I'm in and out my experience at
Chick-fil-A is it's a huge line and we
wait a long time
do you think that that's an issue of
their popularity do you think it's
possible that a company just having a
Dei Department isn't necessarily a bad
thing no it is yeah they're never going
to use that for good it would be like if
they opened like if if imagine if Taco
Bell said announcing the chief Chinese
Communist Party officer there's no
difference none you'd be like what yeah
I've heard it was Korea when they
founded that their prime minister had an
involvement I think was uh prime
minister Moon had involved with some
kind of cult this is like 2020 I think
Korea freaked out they had thousands of
people in the streets I don't think
anyone remembers that but that was
because of the fact that like this in
this difference the Prime Minister but
they they had this person install that
was not part of the Korean government it
wasn't part of like I mean like that's
it's an ulterior motive in your
government and it's similar to that you
know
yeah that's interesting first I've heard
of that yeah
let's grab some more super jets
stinky fingertip says that baseball
player is a Toronto Canada I don't know
their hate speech laws but he may have
been facing fines or even jail time not
just a salary
oh man wow you know
humans are so disappointing sometimes
I kind of just have this it's it you
know it's my fault really it's my fault
growing up in America at a time when we
when we thought highly of our founding
fathers for being strong moral figures
who believed in individual
responsibility personal Liberties it's
it's it's my fault for believing those
things should be inherent in people
because in fact it was a fluke this
country is a rarity is it an oddity that
people would defy the established order
to take command and take control
you know what I think it is you had this
big city you had this big country you
had London you know there's European
cities and people were like I don't want
to live this way isn't it really funny
religious persecution
so they said we're gonna leave
I would rather risk dying
over the oceans yeah I would lather I
would rather lather I would rather land
on Barren Shores than live with these
people
and they did and then those people had
kids and taught those kids and those
people had kids and taught those kids
and then you had a small country where
they were basically all thinking the
same thing get the F away from me so
they severed ties now after hundreds of
years later we have been demoralized and
broken down into lazy vapid individuals
and here's what I wonder
is it just going to take another
American Colonial movement
do a bunch of people just say I'm moving
El Salvador I think what you just
described is a great quote and y'all
probably talked about on the show before
but it's hard times create strong men uh
you know where I'm going strong men
create good times good times create weak
men and weak men create hard times I
think we're literally witnessing that
you know Peter but it's but it's but
it's also spiraling downward yeah Peter
Adia was said that it's only recently
that things have begun to fall apart and
it has a lot to do with the food pyramid
this business plan that the American
government was involved in creating and
pushing on people's propaganda to make
them think that that's what they're
supposed to be eating empty carbs uh
like a total Destruction criminal the
entire food pyramid everything the
government puts it like I've lost my
mind many times reading government
guidelines quote unquote about food and
health it's literally generally you
could just do the opposite of everything
they're telling you this I mean they got
the man in the dress like telling you
how to eat and how to be healthy and
he's also overweight clearly very
healthy guy right he's awesome and
they're telling you this is what you
need to do to get healthy I'll do the
Opposites but working great I wonder if
the answer is uh
doing what the founding fathers and our
ancestors did and straight up get on a
boat and go build your own place well I
you know we'll talk about some of the
the ways Reagan was overrated but one
thing he said which is dead honest
there's nowhere else to go El Salvador
El Salvador we're gonna go build El
Salvador I think there will be a human
revolution on Mars when we start
populating another planet which you know
maybe it seems Fantastical now but it
will happen and when it does there will
be a revolution on that planet and they
will take control of their government
the way that Americans do the expanse
so that's about basically in the show
you've got uh Mars was a colony but it
was heavily militaristic because of the
way you had to live to survive and then
they basically break off and form their
own country or whatever ironically
that's like and maybe people don't know
about this book that's in Gundam too the
same thing happens Mars lines is
basically very militaristic because of
how hard life was and then they would
attack Earth in their store in their
story it makes sense it does if we're
gonna have a colony on Mars it would
require like intense discipline right
obedience and governmental support so
you would have a full military function
definitely to everything yeah they would
not tolerate BS especially if they need
those resources no no way could be that
we colonize the ocean that we build
islands and colonize the ocean
oh that's interesting did you ever see
oh my gosh years ago there there was
this plan for a massive floating tax
shelter that people would Finance to go
live on oh man it was an incredible pipe
dream OMG puppy says Santa Claus was at
the Council of nicaea oh my God
heretic he punched an area that's right
so just know he is checking that list
twice all right
naughty list
he punched one of the other Bishops
wow Santa Claus sounds based yeah I love
that guy
yeah I mean he's going around giving
presents away yeah hilarious just just
clocked him that's a legend and we hope
you know
he's got a mean right hook
yeah let's grab some more Super chats
where are we at
Sparky says news flash Russia is no
longer communist interesting yeah really
whoa didn't know that
all right we get a couple more in here
Seth Klein says recently unemployed and
looking for work not sure if I could
help with anything we are very close to
uh
me just tweeting out there I'm not even
kidding like I've already said several
times if we don't get someone I'm
literally going to Tweet the address and
then we'll set up like a job fair okay
like here here's what we're looking for
here's the address see ya here's the
time
the toughest thing is though is a lot of
these things require some level of skill
like you know it doesn't understand like
someone's got to show up who knows
concrete so we get the concrete done
wiring's got the wiring done
but every time we hire a new company
the same thing happens they're like we
can't find people yep nobody wants to
work
wow add add to that the fact that add to
that the homeless crisis and the illegal
immigration crisis we're done
yeah there's there's an unprecedented
extraction happening on this country
right now
but have you considered that that hurts
my feelings in your mean
and maybe we need more Mean Tweets yeah
maybe the Mean Tweets were the thing
that actually made it made it work they
were fun yeah
let's see where we're at
guitar maker says I was blessed enough
talented enough and lucky enough to have
made my living playing guitar now I'm
retired from the stage and make guitars
as a hobby very close man
Kurt ansem said something since
McDonald's is going fully automated
could you do the same just program a
less beta version of Ian you spend more
time that's better than me yeah sorry to
interrupting so I I
said uh
uh we spend more time shutting down the
pseudo hippie then he brings up I don't
you spend more time
we I bought something called uh I bought
some all-natural hippie deodorant that's
made of like Carnauba wax and like
fragrance and stuff and one of the
scents was dragon's blood and I opened
it up and it smells like your bedroom
the thing about dragon's blood is it
keeps dragons away oh there isn't it
smell they can't stand it yeah it's
called there's an instance called
dragon's blood I haven't burned that's
probably what it is yeah I haven't
burned that one before it's not Champa
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com because we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you where we talk
about Joe Biden's accuser fleeing to
Russia so you don't want to miss it
that'll be on the front page of
timcast.com in just a few minutes you
can follow the show at timcast uh I'm
sorry at Tempest IRL you can follow me
at timcast Seth you want to shout
anything out yeah you can support what
we're doing at uh ultrarightbeer.com I
appreciate everyone that's done so so
far
right on thanks ringing out you guys can
check what we're doing out at Freedom
Tunes we are actually going to be
releasing three videos this week we just
released one today for those of you who
missed the debunkers we're going to be
releasing an episode of that cartoon
tomorrow and then uh another surprise
cartoon on Thursday I hope you all go
over there check it out Ian Crossland
here Seth weathers at Seth weathers on
Twitter thanks for the beer man Ultra
right dude it's delicious I'm still
sipping on it right now and uh for the
record knock Chomp is an Indian
fragrance made with a combination of
sandalwood and either champak or
Frangipani I haven't heard either though
so maybe that's what you're smelling I
don't know bye everyone
uh yeah that was a good one I'm really
glad to meet you in real life Seth to
pleasure same yeah and uh for everyone
else in surge.com you can argue with me
on Twitter I actually talked to Seth on
Twitter a lot yeah funnily enough uh
yeah this has been fun I'll see you guys
in the after hopefully all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in a couple minutes thanks
for hanging out